après des jours d'intenses pilonnages
l'armée russe a réussi à gagner la ville
stratégique de sciez verrou donetsk en
détruisant tous les ponts qui menait
encore l'armée ukrainienne vient
d'annoncer qu'elle a abandonné le centre
de la ville aux forces russes ni les
derniers soldats ukrainien encore sur
place n'ont que deux choix dit ce
représentant des séparatistes pro-russes
ils doivent se rendre ou mourir dans la
ville voisine les sites chance on essaie
d'évacuer le plus de civils possible
tout comme à pau croft à une centaine de
kilomètres de là des résidents de toute
la région convergent chaque jour pour
monter à bord de l'un de ses trains
gratuits en direction de lviv dans
l'ouest du pays comme le rappelait hier
notre maison a été bombardée mes enfants
étaient terrific cette femme alors nous
avons décidé de partir
pendant ce temps la police nationale
ukrainienne a annoncé enquêter sur la
mort de douze mille de ses concitoyens
depuis le début du conflit comme ici
près de butcher ou des enquêteurs
mettent au jour une fosse commune
les victimes avait les mains attachées
dans le dos dix policiers et des traces
de balles dans les genoux et dans la
tête des preuves explicite selon lui que
ces civils ont été torturées avant
d'être froidement abattu ici lice
villeneuve radio canada montréal